فيما يتعلق بالقرار المرتقب لمحكمه العدل
الدوليه باعتقادك كيف تتحضر اسرائيل
لمواجهه اي قرار ممكن ان يصدر غدا على
العدل
الدوليه ام يعني هذه الجزئيه كذلك مهمه
جدا كنا نتحدث عن الاجراءات الدبلوماسيه
اسرائيل بدات كره الثلج تتدحرج منذ الحا
من يناير عندما دخلت المره الاولى الى
محكمه العدل الدوليه ومنذ ذلك الاجراء هي
تعرف جيدا ان بغض النظر عن القرار الذي
ممكن ان يصدر يوم غد ايا كان ال الكره كره
الثلج بدات تتدحرج وبدات تكبر بغض النظر
عن ماهيه القرار ام في نهايه المطاف اذا
لم يكن هنالك ادانه مع اجراءات وما الى
ذلك هي وصمه عار على دبلوماسيه على جبينها
لكنها سوف تتغاضى عنها ليس هذا هو الوقت
بطبيعه الحال سوف تتغاضى عنها على المدى
البعيد ايه سوف تحاول ان تتعافى منها على
المدى البعيد لكن اي ادانه فعليه مع
اجراءات فعليه بطبيعه الحال اسرائيل سوف
تدخل الى ما يسمى باللغه العبريه بالمجان
الى المنطقه الدفاعيه وهذه يعني
استراتيجيه تتخذها اسرائيل عاده عندما تر
نفسها في موقف ضعف دبلوماسي قبل اي شيء
اخر باعتقادي ان الاجراءات الاولى التي
سوف تقوم بها هي كلاسيكيه مهاجمه محكمه
العدل مهاجمه الاطراف هي قامت بذلك من قبل
بمهاجمه جنوب افريقيا وباعتقادي لن تت لن
تسير في تنفيذ القرارات على خطى متسارعه
بل سوف تحول المماطله الى الحد الاذنى حتى
تجد نفسها في الزاويه وفي هذا السياق ايضا
الخارجيه الامريكيه استبقت قرار العدل
الدوليه اليوم الجمعه وقالت ان الادعاءات
بان اسرائيل ترتكب اباده جماعيه لا اساس
لها من الصحه هل هذه حصانه مسبقه ل
لاسرائيل في حال يعني العدل الدوليه ارسلت
قرارها الى الامم
المتحده في عام 2003 وجدت نفسها اسرائيل
لمره الاولى تواجه ادعات ب من لاهاي بكل
ما يتعلق جزئيه جدار الفصل العنصري وهنالك
تقريبا كان شبه اجماع على يعني ادانه ذلك
الجدار ب ووصفه بالجدار فصل عنصري وابار
تيد الولايات المتحده وان كان لديها بعض
التحفظ من ذلك الجدار ولكنها الوحيده التي
وقفت ايه في يعني مع اسرائيل داعمه لها في
كل تلك الواجهه الدبلوماسيه انا باعتقاد
ان هذا الامر بنهايه المطاف يجب ان نتذكر
ان هي تواجه اسرائيل يعني هي تدافع هنا عن
اسرائيل وليس عن حكومه اسرائيل نعم هنالك
ازدواجيه في المعايير بالنسبه للاداره
الامريكيه بكل ما يتعلق الحكومه
الاسرائيليه هي تحاول اضعافها لكن هذا
القرار لا يتعلق بجزئيه جزئيه الحكومه هو
يتعلق بكيونت اسرائيل كدوله وباعتقادي ان
يعني هو كلاسيكي ان نتوقع من الاداره
الامريكيه بان تقوم بالدفاع عنه حتى
بخطوات استباقيه ايهاب جبارين الكاتب
المختص في الشان الاسرائيلي في حيفا شكرا
لك